[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
JOSH LANZET: I know.
Good afternoon.
My gosh.
EMILIO ESTEVEZ: Thank you.
How's lunch?
Is it good?
[LAUGHTER]
JOSH LANZET: I feel
like, if it were just me,
that reception would have made
sense when everyone was just
dead silent.
I get that, guys.
I get that.
Well, thank you so much
for joining us today.
EMILIO ESTEVEZ: Thank you.
JOSH LANZET: I know you
were traveling everywhere.
EMILIO ESTEVEZ: So I've
been on a 35-city tour
for the last seven weeks,
6 and 1/2, seven weeks.
We've been out screening the
film at some film festivals,
at libraries, for
homeless advocacy groups,
and at some shelters.
And the idea was to create
a grassroots awareness
of the film before we
ultimately landed in New York
and did the mainstream media,
which was "The Today Show,"
and Fallon, and Kelly and
Ryan, and all of those.
JOSH LANZET: First name basis.
EMILIO ESTEVEZ:
Even "Rachel Ray."
Yeah, even "Rachel Ray."
I'm exhausted, and I'm
really happy to be back
in LA, even for a moment.
JOSH LANZET: Yeah, I was
going to say, we get you,
and then you disappear.
EMILIO ESTEVEZ: Right.
JOSH LANZET: But yeah, I guess,
my first question for you--
I think that when you were
at the start of your career,
you made a lot of movies that
resonated with a generation.
And I think, as that generation
got older, a lot of the movies
that you started to direct
and pursue from a writing
perspective began to
also resonate with us,
because those kind
of grew with us.
You started to tackle a
little more serious topics
and serious things
of that nature.
was that an intentional choice?
And how did you start kind
of making that shift out?
EMILIO ESTEVEZ: Well, I kind of
took a left turn, if you will,
about 20-some years ago.
I would do one for the studio
or two for the studio and one
for me.
And then it was all for
the studio and none for me.
And then I thought, I'm
doing "Mighty Ducks 3,"
and I'm miserable.
And this is not where
I really wanted to be.
And so I decided to do movies
that spoke to the humanity
and to do films that,
ultimately-- this
is where I've arrived,
especially during this tour
and with this
film, "The Public,"
is that, if you look at the "War
at Home," which we did in '95,
where I played a Vietnam
vet suffering from PTSD,
and then "Bobby," which was
about the day Bobby Kennedy
was shot at the Ambassador
Hotel here in LA,
and, really, what the world
looks like without Bobby
Kennedy, then "The
Way," which was
up about a spiritual
journey that takes place
in the north of Spain along the
Camino de Santiago about grief
and loss, and then "The Public."
All of the movies that
preceded "The Public,"
inform where we are
right now in terms
of where I've wanted to go.
I believe that none of us
walk the planet pain-free.
I think that we all have a
certain amount of trauma.
And it's how we process that
trauma or not process it.
And it's all about degrees.
And so what all of these
movies have in common
is a shared trauma and shared
grief and how we process that.
JOSH LANZET: Yeah.
Yeah, a lot of your
movies resonate with me.
I've seen so many of them.
Before I get into
those, I guess,
you're talking about
doing more movies for you.
Is there a bigger challenge,
I think, in doing some
of those independents?
EMILIO ESTEVEZ: Oh, yeah.
You see what's going
on in movies these days
with the studios.
And in many ways, they sort
of operate like big oil.
They go out there with
their rigs and their drills,
and they drill down
into your wallets.
And they extract
enormous amounts of cash.
When you're an
independent filmmaker,
you're out there with a
divining rod and a shaman, just
trying to figure stuff out.
And you're just like, oh,
we'll get a little money
from this person, a little
money from that person.
And we'll cobble all of
these elements together--
actors, and funding,
and a location,
where you're in a state
that provides a tax rebate,
which is how we ended up
in Ohio and landed in Ohio.
And again, the state
becomes somewhat
of a partner in the
making of the film.
So yeah, they're tough.
Independent movies, they're
tough, not only to get made,
but it seems like
that's the easy part.
The easy part is making it.
The tough part is the
marketing and the distribution.
JOSH LANZET: So you
didn't like going
to 35 cities in seven weeks?
That wasn't--
EMILIO ESTEVEZ: You know what?
I love the country.
And I drive a lot.
I'm on the road quite a bit.
I've got a 12-year-old car.
It's got 280,000 miles on it.
And I've probably driven a
million miles around the United
States in my lifetime
quite easily.
I love this country.
I love seeing what's
going on out there.
And places like Omaha, Nebraska
and Marfa, Texas and Lawrence,
Kansas and Farmington Hills,
just outside of Detroit,
and then, of course,
Cincinnati, where I now have a--
I bought an old building.
I bought a building
that was constructed
in 1881, which is
significant, for me anyway,
because that's the year
that Billy the Kid was
shot and killed, if you
believe that part of the story.
So yeah, built in '81, and
it needs a lot of work.
I'm pretty handy.
And so I've been doing a
lot of the work myself--
and then having
people come behind
me and fix what I screwed up.
JOSH LANZET: Sure.
I just go right to that,
but that makes sense.
That makes sense.
One of things I wanted
to ask you about
was actually Culture
Clash in America.
Really interesting-- for
those that don't know,
Culture Clash is a performance
troupe out of San Francisco.
They do a lot of
different things
as they relate to the
immigrant experience.
You worked with them.
EMILIO ESTEVEZ: I did.
They would be considered
like satirists.
JOSH LANZET: Yes.
Yes.
I was curious, how did
you guys get connected
and what interested
you in that project?
EMILIO ESTEVEZ:
Well, I saw a play
that they had done
downtown, I think,
at the Ahmanson or the Taper,
called "Water and Power."
I met them backstage,
and they said,
they wanted to do
a show and film it.
And we had a mutual
producing friend,
and the guy says, I'll fund
it if you want to direct it,
and we'll put the show on.
So over the course of,
I think, four nights,
we shot the live
show all four times,
and then cobbled together
for the best of those four
performances.
But they're great.
It's Montoya, and
Salinas, and Siguenza.
They're very active, and
they're very into it.
I've lost touch with
them over the years,
but they're wildly talented.
If you don't know
who they are, they're
three extraordinary talents
that you should check out.
JOSH LANZET: Yeah, I really
enjoyed it-- very hard to find,
in case anyone is
looking for it.
EMILIO ESTEVEZ: Well, I don't
know if it ever got released.
JOSH LANZET: I had to go to the
production company to get it.
EMILIO ESTEVEZ: Arenas?
Was it the Arenas?
JOSH LANZET: Yes,
Arenas Entertainment.
And it was tough.
And I was curious--
I guess my last question
on that, I believe--
and please correct me if I'm
wrong-- that you spent about,
I think, six months
living in Mexico,
I think, when your dad
was shooting "Catch 22."
Is that right?
EMILIO ESTEVEZ: Right.
JOSH LANZET: You're
looking at me.
It's so suspicious.
EMILIO ESTEVEZ: Where
are we going with this?
JOSH LANZET: I was just
curious if that experience made
you more interested
in a project that
was talking about the
immigrant experience
and doing Culture Clash.
EMILIO ESTEVEZ: Well, no.
I never wanted to
leave New York.
So we left New York in 1969.
It was the only city
that I ever really knew.
I love New York.
It's probably why I'm
attracted to Cincinnati,
because it reminds me of New
York in a smaller way, in 1969.
In neighborhoods,
you could walk.
You'd be out on the street
and feel very comfortable,
even back then.
I was just there last week,
and if you've been-- well,
you're from there.
JOSH LANZET: Yeah.
EMILIO ESTEVEZ: It's crazy.
It's almost impossible
to navigate.
It wasn't that.
And Cincinnati is very similar
to what New York was like then.
But it was interesting to
go to Mexico for that film,
because that was
directed by Mike Nichols.
He was just coming
off of "The Graduate,"
and he had everyone in
the world in that film,
including Orson Welles, and
Alan Arkin, and Art Garfunkel,
who I was a huge Art--
Simon Garfunkel--
At six years old, I knew every
song that they had recorded.
I was a wild fanatic
of Simon Garfunkel.
And now, Art Garfunkel
is in this movie.
I'm thinking, I'm going
to have an opportunity
to meet Art Garfunkel.
This is going to be insane.
This is a dream.
And so when we first
got there, they
put us in a really nice
hotel, which we only
stayed in for about a
week, because my dad had
a very small role.
So they said, you're
going to stay here a week
until you get set up in a
house or apartment later.
So it's great.
So I was sitting at a table with
my mom and my sister, Renée.
And right next to us--
our table was in
the middle, and then
there was a two-top
next to us there,
and it was Mike Nichols
and Art Garfunkel,
like, five feet away.
And my little sister
began to eat the butter
on the table a cube at a time.
And my mom kept pulling it away.
And somehow, she got
her hands on it again
and ate more butter and more
butter, and then, of course,
got sick to her stomach and
puked all over the table.
Now, of course, I have
a gag reflex, which is--
right.
And so, of course,
I smelled the vomit,
and I turned to Art Garfunkel,
and I puked all over the floor.
And I remember
Garfunkel just sort
of looking up from his
eggs in absolute disgust
and shook his head.
And I never met him.
[LAUGHTER]
I never met him.
JOSH LANZET: He probably
remembers you, though.
EMILIO ESTEVEZ: And my mom
just grabbed both of us
and marched us out.
JOSH LANZET: That's
some troubled water.
EMILIO ESTEVEZ: Heart-breaking
story, of course.
[LAUGHS]
JOSH LANZET: Well,
speaking of, I mean, you
named a lot of great actors
that were in that movie.
You happen to employ so many
actors in all of your films,
especially-- this is
an intimidating poster
to look at, let alone to
actually see this film.
But people you've worked with,
like Sir Anthony Hopkins,
you worked with Helen Hunt.
The number of people
just on this poster alone
that you've worked with, is
that intimidating at all?
EMILIO ESTEVEZ: Yes.
I mean, we were on the set of
"Bobby," and Shia LaBeouf, who
was relative unknown at that
time, pulled me aside and says,
Emilio, I'm so confused.
I don't know where to look.
I don't know who to stare at.
There's so many huge
actors on this film.
I'm so intimidated.
And I said, let me tell you
something. (WHISPERS) I am,
too.
So yeah.
But I love actors.
I love the process.
I love ensemble films.
I love the films
of Altman, and I
feel like, a lot of what
I've been doing lately
is influenced by that.
But also, as an actor, the films
that I have really scored in
have been ensemble pictures.
You look at "The Breakfast
Club," "St, Elmo's Fire,"
"Young Guns," even "The Mighty
Ducks" to a lesser extent,
have been all ensemble pictures.
And it allows you to lean
on your fellow cast members.
It allows you to sort of
pass the ball off and let
them run with it for a while.
I think that I'm better suited
in an ensemble environment.
And so obviously, I'm now
creating them for myself.
JOSH LANZET: Yeah, almost
every one of your movies
is just like
show-stopping person
after show-stopping person.
You were talking about,
you were in ensembles.
Did you take any lessons
from being in ensembles
from the directors
you worked with
and how they kind of wrangled
that many talented people?
EMILIO ESTEVEZ: Well,
you know, probably,
to a certain extent, yeah.
I mean, Joel Schumacher did
"St. Elmo's Fire," John Hughes,
of course, "Breakfast Club."
Those were early movies
for me, and, of course,
you're influenced
by your early days.
JOSH LANZET: Sure.
EMILIO ESTEVEZ:
And so yeah, being
on the set, watching
them work, I
would often come
to work on my days
off just to watch
the directors and try
to understand their process.
I was very interested in
directing at a very young age.
In fact, I did it
when I shouldn't have.
I directed my first film.
It was dreadful.
But I wrote the script,
directed it, starred in it.
It was a movie called "Wisdom."
I was 23 years old, and I wanted
to be the youngest writer,
director, actor in Hollywood.
Because Welles had done it
with "Citizen Kane" at 26.
And I was like, I've
got to beat Welles.
So it was just absolute hubris.
And so I write the script, and
we put this cast together that
included Demi Moore,
and Tom Skerritt,
and Veronica Cartwright--
both from "Alien"--
and who else was in it?
A couple other actors that
you may or may not know.
Anyway, so we go off.
We make this film.
I have this amazing
behind-the-scenes talent.
Robert Wise, the director of
"Sound of Music" and "West Side
Story," is my
executive producer.
And on the set every
day, Michael Kahn,
who is Steven Spielberg's
editor, cutting the film.
Danny Elfman, from Oingo
Boingo, and the composer,
it's his second score after
Tim Burton's "Pee Wee's Big
Adventure."
And I stood outside, I think,
it was the Pantages Theater,
with my script after an
Oingo Bongo concert, like,
Mr. Elfman, I'm going to
direct a movie someday.
And I really want you to do
the score, and he did it.
Dennis Gassner, who's
won several Oscars,
was the production designer.
Adam Greenberg, who'd just shot
"The Terminator" was my DP.
I mean, it's ridiculous.
It was an embarrassment
of riches on this film.
And I had a terrible
script, and nobody told me.
Or if they did, I
wasn't listening.
And so I got my
ass handed to me.
And just to top it--
to come back around
to the Orson Welles of it all,
the "LA Weekly" did a review,
and they devoted a
ton of ink to it,
I mean, a ton, like, two pages.
And I open it up,
and the headline
was "Ain't No Rosebud."
JOSH LANZET: Oof.
[AUDIENCE EXCLAIMS]
EMILIO ESTEVEZ: I was
like, OK, I deserved that.
Yeah, it was pretty devastating.
I stopped reading
the "LA Weekly."
[LAUGHTER]
JOSH LANZET: You don't
need a sled in Los Angeles.
That's what I've always felt.
You know, you don't need that.
I have to ask this.
I used to work a lot.
When I was in high school,
I used to a lot of theater
with my sister.
I cannot even fathom directing
a family member in anything.
You have worked with both
Charlie and your father
multiple times.
EMILIO ESTEVEZ: That's right.
JOSH LANZET: What is it
like directing family?
Is one of them harder to
direct than the other, more
intimidating?
EMILIO ESTEVEZ: Yeah.
I mean, they both are.
When you direct
family, you know where
all the buttons are, because
you helped build the machine.
So there were moments
where my dad and I
would clash on the way.
And when we started
off on that--
I mean, my dad's
a devout Catholic,
and he really wanted the film
to be reflective of that.
And I said, you know what?
We've got to get our arms
around it being, yes,
we're on a Christian pilgrimage.
It ends on the
Camino de Santiago.
Yes, you are Catholic.
But the character
isn't, so can you
separate yourself from that.
He said, no.
I said, well, you're
going to have to.
And you're going to have
to fight your instinct
to make this a Catholic movie.
And in fact, we
clashed quite a bit
about that, because
I wanted the film
to be accessible to
non-Catholics as well.
I'm not a practicing Catholic.
I am what people would
call a work in progress
in terms of my faith.
I am more of a humanist.
JOSH LANZET: Sure.
So was the moment
in the way when
he receives the rosary
beads, was that originally
in the script.
EMILIO ESTEVEZ:
No, that was him.
He says, I want to
receive some rosary beads.
So I was like, great.
JOSH LANZET: Yeah.
And last question before
I get to "The Public."
I just have to quickly ask
about James Duff's "Home
Front," which you adapted
into "The War at Home."
EMILIO ESTEVEZ: That's right.
JOSH LANZET: How much more
challenging was it to adapt
something from an
incredible play--
one of my favorite plays--
to adapt something from that
and a rather challenging play,
generally, into your film?
EMILIO ESTEVEZ: Did you and your
sister play Karen and Jeremy?
JOSH LANZET: I played
Jeremy, but not with her.
EMILIO ESTEVEZ: OK.
It's a great monologue, right?
JOSH LANZET: Super-hard to--
when you leave every day, that
feeling doesn't leave you.
EMILIO ESTEVEZ: Right.
Now you remember the
monologue about his friend
who kills himself?
JOSH LANZET: Brady.
EMILIO ESTEVEZ: Brady.
JOSH LANZET: Yeah.
EMILIO ESTEVEZ:
You remember that?
It was a long monologue.
We filmed it.
And for those of
you who don't know,
it's a story about a
Vietnam vet, which I played,
which you played as well.
JOSH LANZET: Not as well.
EMILIO ESTEVEZ: Suffering
from PTSD, in a home,
in his folks' house, in Texas.
Kathy Bates played my mother.
My dad played my dad.
And Kimberly Williams
played Karen.
And it's a very tough play.
I think, when it
opened on Broadway,
Carroll O'Connor played
Bob and Frances Sternhagen
played the mom.
And I think it closed
in, like, two weeks.
It was not a long run.
It was a very, very tough play.
So James Duff
wanted to open it up
for the film, which I
thought was a great idea.
But it was a very difficult role
to not only play, but direct
myself playing.
And so I did that
monologue, which you know,
and it was terrible.
It was absolutely terrible.
And I was just like, OK,
the whole movie stops.
And so we say, as
filmmakers, oftentimes,
you have to kill your babies.
And this was one
of those moments,
where the movie was going along.
Its going along.
The audience is laughing.
They're involved.
Now, there's this monologue,
and it brought the film
to a screeching halt.
And I stepped back
and I said, it's got to go.
And that was it.
But Duff was--
James Duff, if you
don't know him,
also created the show with
Kyra Sedgwick called--
JOSH LANZET: "Closer?"
EMILIO ESTEVEZ: "Closer," yeah.
Terrific writer and
was very much a partner
during the creation of that.
JOSH LANZET: That's awesome.
I have to get to "The Public."
I have so many questions.
"The Public" was inspired by
an essay called "Written Off,"
by Chip Ward.
EMILIO ESTEVEZ: That's right.
JOSH LANZET: What drew you
about that specific essay that
resonated with you?
Because I believe this was
over 10 years in the making.
EMILIO ESTEVEZ: Right.
Last week, was the
12th anniversary
of the publication of that
piece in the "LA Times--"
April 1, 2007.
And so I read this piece.
It was about how
libraries have become
daytime de-facto homeless
shelters, how librarians
are now tasked with
being first responders,
and de-facto social workers.
And at the end of the
piece, he asked the reader,
are you doing enough to remedy
this issue of homelessness
in America?
What can you do?
So I stepped back from that.
I said, OK, I'm a filmmaker.
I'm a storyteller.
I might be able
to find something.
I was looking for a
follow-up piece to "Bobby."
So I went back to the downtown
LAPL, the central branch,
to hang out and just observe.
And what Ward was
talking about was not
just localized to
Salt Lake City,
but it was, in
fact, an epidemic.
And so I began to imagine
what the story would
look like on a chilly night.
You have the patron stage in
old-fashioned '60s sit-in,
how the law enforcement
would react,
how the media might spin it.
And if there was a politician
in the middle of a mayoral race,
how might he spin it for
his own political gain?
And so imagine, over
these last 12 years,
you're turning on the TV.
You're opening up the newspaper.
You're going online
to read your news,
and you're watching all of these
stories unfold, including now,
librarians are trained
in the use of Narcan,
because the overdoses
in libraries,
that's become epidemic.
JOSH LANZET: Wow.
One of the biggest themes
that I spotted in this movie,
which is not hard to spot, is
the ideas of climate change,
everything from the cold snap.
There's a discussion earlier in
the film between your character
and Jena Malone's character
about minimizing your carbon
footprint.
What about that side-- because
I know, in the original essay,
it's touched on, but not
nearly as much as you went--
what drove you to go in as
deep as you did on that?
EMILIO ESTEVEZ:
Well, what happened
was, in the actual location,
when we first scouted it,
there was no polar bear.
And if you haven't
seen the movie,
there's a polar bear in
the middle of the library,
in the lobby.
So that polar bear wasn't there.
In fact, the Natural
History Museum
is renovating in Cincinnati, and
they spread out their exhibits
all over the city.
So for the three years,
this polar bear--
I think his time is up in May.
They're going to take
him back to the museum.
Again, before the polar bear
got there, I said, great.
We're going to use this library.
Terrific.
Came back with the crew.
Now, there's this
15-foot polar bear.
I thought, OK, I can't
shoot around this.
I have to include it.
I need this lobby.
I said, how can I use this bear
to help inform Jena Malone's
character even more?
And again, she's a bit of a
"couch-tivist" in the film.
She's not active,
except on social media.
So she posts memes,
and she thinks
she's doing the right thing.
And in fact, she
doesn't understand
what community service
looks like until the end
of the movie.
She has that woke
moment, but it doesn't
happen until much later.
So yeah, I'm grateful
to this polar bear,
which the locals in the
library had named Barry White.
JOSH LANZET: Of
course, they did.
That makes sense.
I hate this phrasing,
but another big character
in the film, is "The
Grapes of Wrath."
"Grapes of Wrath" comes out
multiple times in the film.
One of the quotes
that you included
was, "wherever there's a fight
so hungry people can eat,
I'll be there."
EMILIO ESTEVEZ: That's right.
JOSH LANZET: Part of that,
when I was watching the movie,
kind of felt almost like
you were there for the fight
after reading Chip Ward's essay.
That's why you were
there making that,
and that was kind of
your thematic statement.
EMILIO ESTEVEZ: I like that.
JOSH LANZET: Oh.
EMILIO ESTEVEZ:
Yeah, that was good.
JOSH LANZET: Well,
that's our time, guys.
[LAUGHTER]
But did you see a lot of
connections when you were first
starting to write "The
Public" between that
and "The Grapes of Wrath?"
Did that immediately
come to you?
EMILIO ESTEVEZ: No,
"Grapes of Wrath"
didn't immediately land for me.
Again, the first draft of the
script was super-didactic.
And it was that speech--
people are dying on the
streets, and da-da-da.
It was so on the nose.
It was a platitude that
the movie couldn't sustain.
And so I said, how can
I say the same thing
without actually saying it?
And to use Steinbeck's words
and to have those come back up--
you know, "Grapes of Wrath"
is going to celebrate
its 80th anniversary this year.
It was published April 14, 1939.
So those words are, I
believe, as relevant now
as they were when
he first wrote them.
He was writing
about what he saw,
which was a great injustice
and a great sorrow.
And he felt that the success
that we were experiencing
as a country were
being overshadowed
by these enormous failures.
JOSH LANZET: Yeah.
I also noticed that
just even around a lot
of the pieces in
your movies, not only
does literature play a part.
I've noticed that
addiction pops up
in a few of your
different films.
Obviously, it's pretty
prominent in "The Public,"
even down to the
cigarettes that, I believe,
the character's name is Sarah
was smoking in "The Way."
EMILIO ESTEVEZ:
Joost, the Dutchman,
was smoking pot throughout
the whole thing.
JOSH LANZET: And eating a lot.
Just saying.
Looked good, though.
I was hungry.
What were you hoping that
people would take away,
I guess, from your
commentary on addiction,
whether across films or
specifically in "The Public?"
EMILIO ESTEVEZ:
Well, I think, again,
we all self-medicate
to a certain extent.
Some of it is over the counter
or over the liquor counter.
Some of it is by prescription,
and some of it is street drugs.
Of course, nobody in this
room I'm referring to.
JOSH LANZET: Of course.
EMILIO ESTEVEZ: Nor me.
But there is a certain
amount of self-medication
that is very prevalent
in the culture.
I underscore it and
highlight it in my films,
because again, these are
movies about people and people
who are, again, dealing
with their trauma.
And one of the ways that so
many of us deal with our trauma
is by and through
self-medication.
JOSH LANZET: This took place
in Cincinnati, as you said.
Your mother, I believe,
was from there.
EMILIO ESTEVEZ: Born in Cincy.
My dad's from Dayton.
JOSH LANZET: Did
either of them get
to sneak in anything
about their experiences
there as they were
talking to you?
Like, you know, I used to
love this place in Cincinnati.
Put it in.
EMILIO ESTEVEZ: No.
JOSH LANZET: No?
EMILIO ESTEVEZ: No,
neither one of them.
JOSH LANZET: Really?
EMILIO ESTEVEZ: Yeah.
JOSH LANZET: Did
you talk to her?
Was she really happy that
you were putting the movie
in Cincinnati?
EMILIO ESTEVEZ:
Well, my mom was born
in a home for unwed mothers.
And so imagine, in 1939, that
was a pretty unpopular place
to be born in.
So her mom, she wasn't ready
to be a mom when she had her.
And so she was taken
across the river
to be raised by
her grandparents.
So her experience in
Cincinnati was limited.
I think they've torn down the
building where she was born.
I was looking all around
for her birth records
and couldn't find them.
JOSH LANZET: Obviously,
you have so much free time.
EMILIO ESTEVEZ: Exactly.
JOSH LANZET: I have to
say, I'll never here
"I Can See Clearly
Now" by Johnny
Nash ever again in the same way.
If you haven't seen
the film, you need to.
I don't want to spoil
anything, but oh, boy.
How did you choose that
song for such a pivotal part
of the film?
EMILIO ESTEVEZ: Well,
so out of context,
it's tough to talk about.
Because it plays
a part, especially
in the ending of the film.
But the end of the
film was originally
going to be a Journey song.
It was "Don't Stop
Believing" by Journey,
which, again, used quite often.
We hear it in
commercials, other films.
It had been in the
script for years.
And two weeks before we were
to start shooting, they said,
you can't have it.
I said, who said?
They said, well, they're just
not going to grant the rights.
And so I said, what
do I need to do?
Because I'd already learned the
song, which my character sings.
And so they said, you have
to write Steve, and Neil,
and the rest of the group.
You have to beg them.
So I did.
I sat on the computer,
and I crafted
this beautiful letter basically
saying, I'm begging you.
This is what the movie's about.
The song's not going to
be used in a silly way.
They still said no.
So I thought, OK, what to do?
I was at a friend's
house in Cincinnati.
And "I Can See Clearly Now" came
on his Spotify or one of them--
Pandora maybe.
And I said, play that again.
Play that again.
And it became the
song for the end.
JOSH LANZET: Yeah, I can't
hear it the same now.
EMILIO ESTEVEZ:
Right, of course.
JOSH LANZET: Again, watch it.
While we're talking
about music overall,
this seems to be the first
movie that really prominently
featured hip hop of the
movies that you've done
and also featured one
of the bigger names,
I think, in hip hop
history in Rhymefest,
also appears in here.
How did you come to
incorporating hip hop so much
in here and also bringing
Rhymefest into that movie?
EMILIO ESTEVEZ: So Che came
to the film in a weird way,
because he was
originally suggested
by my mother, who had seen
Che in a documentary called
"In My Father's House."
And the documentary was
essentially about his reunion
with his dad.
His dad was homeless
for 30 years.
When Che finally was
able to connect with him,
his father said, the only place
I'm comfortable meeting you
is in the local public library.
So they met.
They made this documentary.
My mom saw it.
She said, hey, you're casting.
You should know this guy is.
He's a really
fascinating character.
And he has lived
experience, which
could actually help
you along the way
as you're making this film.
And so I called Che.
We connected.
I said, I'm interested in
having you be a part of this
as an actor.
And if you know
the song, "Glory,"
that was in the film "Selma,"
he was the third writer on that.
So it was Common and John
Legend that wrote that.
And they won the
Oscar and, I guess,
all the awards for that song.
So Che said, I'm game.
I want to be a part of this.
And then once he arrived,
and "I Can See Clearly Now"
was chosen as one of the end
songs of the film, he said,
I want to rerecord this, and
I want to write an original.
And I want to write another.
So I was like, dude, have at it.
So we have three original
Rhymefest songs in the film.
"Make Noise," he recorded
with Tariq Trotter,
better known as Black Thought,
and they're really good tunes.
And you're talking about
not being able to find them.
JOSH LANZET: I wasn't
going to say anything.
EMILIO ESTEVEZ: I think
we're going to know--
are they going to be out,
Mark, they say, today?
Today?
They're going to be out?
Yeah, they'll be out today.
JOSH LANZET: Good.
They're great.
That's why I was asking.
I wasn't complaining.
Yeah, and I think,
what's interesting is
his performance was incredible.
He played one of the people
experiencing homelessness.
I believe that you also brought
people who were actually
in that position in Cincinnati,
who are currently homeless,
as part of the film.
EMILIO ESTEVEZ: Yes, we
invited them to participate.
And the only criteria
was, once you're
in this lockdown
situation, I need you
to come back the next night.
You can't just work one
day and then take off.
I need you to be consistent.
And the idea of needing
to be counted on
made a difference
in their lives.
And they were counted
on, and they showed up.
And they were an important
part of our overall group.
JOSH LANZET: That's incredible.
And the last question
I have for you--
I think, when we
look, this movie
is saying a lot of things.
And I think it's pulled a
lot of people's attention.
It's definitely
pulled my attention
to a lot of what we're facing
as a country right now,
especially as
weather's changing.
And a lot of people still
don't have a place to be.
What do you want us as
audiences to take away?
What can we do?
EMILIO ESTEVEZ: Well,
again, going to the article,
what can we do?
What more can we do?
And how do we get our
arms around this issue?
And especially in Los
Angeles, where real estate
comes with such a premium.
My daughter's been forced
to move now three times.
She got priced out
of the LA market.
She's living in Long
Beach now, where
she has a great
place, but, again,
very far away from
where she works.
So OK, we've got the money
through measure Triple
H, $1 billion for 10,000 units.
But we have 57,000 in LA alone--
individuals experiencing
homelessness.
So 10,000 units doesn't
even scratch the surface.
What's important is
permanent supportive housing.
So again, it's sort of
a chicken-and-egg thing,
because a lot of
neighborhoods don't
want that permanent supportive
housing in their backyard.
So there's the NIMBY issue.
Real estate coming with a
premium, the people who,
like my daughter, who
can't afford to live here.
So there's the issue
of where and how.
25% of those experiencing
homelessness are vets.
20% are children.
And here's a
staggering statistic--
11% of California
State college students
are couch-surfing or
living in their car.
I mean, staggering-- 11%.
So how are you going to get
an education if you're just
thinking about survival?
So the issue is enormous.
But when you look at
homelessness, and you look
at what got us to where
we are right now--
Carter signed the Mental Health
Services Act into law in 1980.
It was repealed the next year
by the incoming administration,
so that was a big hit.
Then that same administration,
under the Omnibus Budget,
cut HUD by 77%.
So you had these
two enormous strikes
against the poor,
and the marginalized,
and the mentally ill.
And that is how we've gotten
to, ultimately, where we are.
Clinton's Welfare Reform
Act also didn't help.
But homelessness has only been
with us, really, for 40 years,
in earnest.
And so if it only took 40
years to get us to this place
right now, I believe that we
can get our arms around it.
And we need to stop
bringing our own bias to how
we look at people on the
street and stop assigning
a story to that individual.
Because we don't know
how they got there.
People assign stories to
all of us all the time.
They assume they
know how we live
or how we arrived
at a certain place.
We need to stop
doing that when we
see an individual
experiencing homelessness.
And we need to say, you know,
that is a person with a name,
and a face, and history.
And they need help.
And homelessness
is not a condition.
It's a situation.
And here's another staggering
number-- and you probably
know this-- but EA,
Emergency Assistance,
for an individual on the
street cost $68,000 per year.
You put a roof over that
same individual's head,
it goes down to 15 grand.
And we all pay for that anyway.
So how do we pay less?
How do we build the housing?
Where do we build the housing?
Those are the big questions that
we need to get our arms around.
Because I'm not OK with it.
I don't think anybody in
this room is OK with it.
You can't be immune
living in this city, where
there is such immense
wealth, and not be--
It's heartbreaking
what's going on.
The discarded, and
the marginalized,
and disenfranchised, and the
poor, they need our help.
And I think it's
criminal on our part
not to figure out
how to solve this.
JOSH LANZET: Yeah.
Well, thank you so much
for your time today.
I really, really appreciate it.
EMILIO ESTEVEZ: Thank you.
JOSH LANZET: Great
having you here.
EMILIO ESTEVEZ: Appreciate it.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]